and what works is act i believe
acceptance
and
commitment therapy which is a cbt
technique so then last night i was
telling myself you know what try that
out accept these thoughts and i'm not
exactly sure what it means to accept
them i don't precisely think it means
entertain them but at least meet them
not with horror and dread and avoidance
but just say that's okay man you think
like that some people feel like that
sometimes so i started doing that and
last night was the first time in the
three weeks since i've had this that i
felt absolutely like my regular self
almost from five minutes of this quote
unquote acceptance therapy and then i
woke up this morning felt like my
regular self like i'm behind my eyes i
have i'm in this world
that was fascinating
okay so i said quite a few statements
right there i'm sure there's plenty you
want to comment on what i'm also
interested in for you to put a pin in
your hat is what the heck does this
self-acceptance self-love if that seemed
the same mean in terms of the free
energy principle okay so i've basically
just poured myself out there
there you go sorry carl for you to pick
up all those pieces i know it's a huge
responsibility i trust you you're
someone who studies this you're
extremely extremely bright and you have
such a wealth of knowledge and i do feel
like what i'm going through is not
something terribly unique i do feel like
this is something that many people who
are on this journey of understanding the
world and consciousness in their place
go through this perhaps at some point
i think i was trying to emphasize that
by saying that you know it is a gift
that you're able to have these
existential crises um your there are
dangers that lurk which you've clearly
encountered but at the end of the day
the very fact that you can entertain
these counterfactuals
is you know quite remarkable you know
to my mind it's it would be the highest
expression of the human condition just
to consider we are those alternative
hypotheses where bits of our humanity
are just not there anymore or have a a
different disposition or relationship to
reality or indeed other people but lots
of things you said it made a lot of
sense
from simple things like you know
soliciting reassurance from others that
you don't have to do um any more work in
terms of preparing yourself for being a
good a good
expounder of ideas or or or interviewer
or book writer or or whatever and you
know that's exactly what you should be
doing that's that's exactly
securing evidence for yourself models of
an affirmatory sort
and the more you do that then the more
the more that model will be fit for
purpose and you will have the right kind
of marginal maximizing your marginal
likelihood but
you're in a difficult position because
your job is actually to explore other
ways of making sense of things and other
ways of thinking things like you you're
compelled to explore alternative
hypotheses um and you know
you've described um
the you know the potential um
nihilism and um um that i presume quite
nightmarish um i can't now remember my
nightmares but i imagine that all of us
do go through so we have nightmares as
children i think you stop having true
nightmares in your 30s and 40s but uh
you know
that sort of you know before you've
really got that grip and maintain that
grip
on
selfhood and
you in your in your lived uh in your
lived world as part of that and engage
with that world before you've got there
you know it must be absolutely awful and
you know nihilistic to to occasionally
lose that and then you know worrying
that you're never going to get it back
it does remind me of certain um
certain um drug-induced states you know
i i can imagine that you're the kind of
person who would be very frightened of
having a very bad trip um and i think
very frightened of having one yeah yeah
so that that is correct and luckily i
wasn't well what i imagined what i was
going through would
feels like how someone would feel on a
on a terrible psychedelic trip
yes
um and it's interesting you bring up
psychedelics because of course you know
um
there is a move um
in uh sort of pharmacologically assisted
talking therapists you know to to use
psychedelics simply um not to aspire to
i don't know what ego death means but i
i i can have a guess at it from the
point of view of meditation and
mindfulness
but there's a really interesting
connection between
the use of
psychedelics um and the aspiration
of
many
um meditation-like practices um that
would i think subsume the intent
internal attention states um of um of
meditation and your current practices of
mindfulness which is really to try and
redirect your attention
to the sensorium and usually the
intercepted parts of it so it's like
breathing for example
so this is the exact opposite of what
you've been doing it's exactly
deploying
that attention
all that um
game control we're talking about in
terms of selecting
what kind of information sensory
information sensory states to
engage and um
determine your belief updating
so putting it putting all that attention
out to the sensory side of your deep
hierarchical models your your constructs
uh what you're doing is the opposite you
you you've been actually wandering
around at the deeper the highest levels
of these hierarchical models
sorry so in back when we were initially
talking and it said there's a black box
the input output and then there are two
black boxes it's as if you're saying pay
attention to the sensory forget about
the action we haven't talked much about
the action though obviously as in body
creatures sensory in action are tied
it's as if what i've been doing was
staying within the box and creating my
little sensations and actions within
there as little loops and you're saying
pay attention to the senses that come
from the outside is that what you're
saying or yes well i'm not saying you
should do you you you will do um
everything uh
in the right way and under the free
energy principle um what i'm saying is
that
what i'm just saying is that the
skilled practitioners of mindfulness and
meditation i would imagine of the kind
that would lead to ego death or
i'm not quite sure what that means
it
would
employ exactly the same kind of
internally mediated and sometimes if you
very skilled volitionally called forth
mechanisms um that are actually um
targeted by psychedelics
[Music]
require you
now to do all your belief updating and
evidence assimilation and sense making
at the much more the input level of the
black box not at the if you like the
highest level which you could think of
as an output in terms of selecting the
plans and what am i going to do next and
what kind of person am i narratives that
we give ourselves that contextualize
the way that we behave and the other
things that we do um so you know i think
this mechanistically a really
interesting connection between the
notion of you ruminating going in
circles around your head exploring every
darker and darker
corners of your mind and different
hypotheses for which there's very little
evidence available simply because you're
not attending to the censorium you're
not talking to anybody
you're not for example you're not you're
not focusing on your breathing and
indeed you try and supplement that with
an elastic band just to get yourself
back to the sensoria
that's interesting
so and i i think that you know
you might you may
i guess you probably are um
skilled in meditation um but that kind i
think the objective of um becoming a
skilled practitioner of mindfulness or
meditation is simply to get some
volitional control over that sort of
attention
um that is paid to these deeper
machinations versus attention that is
paid to the censorium that underwrites
the psychedelic aspect the
the um the allure of just sensory uh
patterns and um
um
the sensations um and textures that you
get you know when taking psychedelics so
you know getting control of the balance
um um so it's not the fact you're
attending to your breathing which is
important is the fact that you could
volitionally redirect your attention
away from selfhood um
so but you seem to have got control um
by this acceptance and it strikes me
that you know in the absence of um
feelings of an emotional sort that were
articulated in your description in terms
of you know i'm an awful person i'm not
fit for purpose i i
i'm not well prepared um
i um i'm not able to man up and own this
ego uh ego death uh
but quite emotional constructs effective
valence um aspects they are also
hypotheses they're also explanations so
the idea is that you know anything that
you can talk about has to be part of an
explanation for particular ways of being
that you know i can be a worthless
person or if this is i am a worthless
person i'm not with this person uh you
know and you since uh i'm i'm
in a state of anxiety i'm not in the
strength of anxiety we have to recognize
when we are anxious anxious is just a
state of being um which is necessarily
called for in certain situations that
rebounds this attention or precision
weighting in
computational psychiatry
to make your belief updating fit for
purpose in this particular in this
particular context and what i'm trying
to get to
is why acceptance might have worked
because i imagine that if you were
suddenly found yourself ruminating and
locked into those ruminations
then very much akin to someone on a bad
trip who thinks ah i am going to be
locked in this forever this is going to
be my uncertain state of being for
eternity
because there is no reality that's how
it feels sorry how felt yep
that
that feeling
will well if that is true i must be
feeling anxious you are then going to
look for evidence that you're feeling
anxious
and because you are anxious
you will experience
certain cardiac acceleration certain
interceptive
flight or fl fright-like responses
that will supply evidence that you are
anxious
and then that becomes evidence yes i am
right i am now in a state of nihilism
i do not exist and i should be anxious
about that and yes i am anxious so you
get into
a vicious circle so this is a sort of
good old-fashioned cognitive behavioral
explanation for things like panic
attacks that you know you quite
reasonably in an entirely base optimal
way
make sense of intraceptive bodily gut
feelings literally
you make sense of that
with the hypothesis oh i must be in an
anxious state of being
and that
conclusion the hypothesis gen then
generates autonomic actions that are
realized reflexively in the way we
talked about uh when we're looking at
the parkinson's idea um and that will be
reflected in terms of cardiac
acceleration uh neuroendocrine releases
uh into your body and your body will
change and your body will supply signals
interceptive evidence yes i am anxious
so it's again a self-fulfilling prophecy
in exactly the same way the idea motor
theory means that raising my hand
is just
a realization of my beliefs but i can
literally raise my levels of anxiety in
exactly the same way but invisibly from
the outside but not when i can sense my
own body
so
if you got yourself caught up into this
joint hypothesis
i
i'm in a nihilistic existential state
and i should be really worried about
this and anxious about this
then it is quite understandable
that you are going to use
signals of anxiety and angst generated
by your body as evidence yes i am now
divorced from reality i'm an person i am
you know in a in a dark and nihilistic
um
place and there could be no other place
there could be no reality
that's a hypothesis
if you can just wait
for the evidence
that that hypothesis is incorrect
simply by letting your body calm down so
there is no further evidence of any
anxiety
then you can find secure even from your
own body without talking to somebody you
can secure evidence are the hypothesis
that i am in a state of internal
nihilism and anxiety
is a silly hypothesis because the
evidence refutes it i can now feel my
cur
not possibly personally but you you will
synthesize all your interceptive
feelings
um in a way
that
provides evidence against the fact that
now i am a deeply nihilistic um anxious
state i think that just is the
motivation for the acceptance it is
pushing through
to get to a state of mind and a state of
body
literally you know realizing you're good
and making sense of your gut feelings
so that you can now refute the joint
hypothesis that i am uh in a state of
nihilism and i should be jolly
frightened of others
because there's no evidence that you're
frightened anymore so this was just a
piece of um
hypothesis building
of a you know a very sophisticated and
um
philosophical source you know the
highest level of exploring alternative
ways of relating to the world you now
have i think a very useful insight
into what into the gift of retaining
selfhood that we i think we all we all
take it for granted but it's quite a
fragile thing you know uh luckily um you
know
most of us get through the day if not
hopefully uh most of our lives you know
by retaining that grip and just you know
continue securing evidence that this is
the right hypothesis i'm a person i am
me i am functional this is you know this
is the way i meant to be and these are
the kinds of things i do and the kinds
of people i talk to but that is such a
fragile self-assembled and had to be
maintained hypothesis that you do
you know that fragility i think only is
revealed occasionally and only to some
people when they have the alternative
prophecies that you know i [ __ ] i'm not
me or my or me is not quite as
functional as i thought i was or i'm
several me or me
me
i am only me and there is no reality out
there
you